ariana grande kicked off her sweetener
tour and it's popping we see this and we
like this Ariana the 7 ring singer
pulled out all the stops at her first
concert in album II New York Monday
night ariana did not disappoint she
belted off notes as high as her ponytail
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
but Ari was also feeling a little low
after wrapping her first tour stop she
wrote this my mind is all over the place
and very emotional thank you I don't
know what I'm posting right now to be
honest at all I'll hit you tomorrow
because tonight was too much Ariana's
thanks to her ex Mac Miller was one of
the most emotional parts of the
sweetener experience she paid tribute to
the late rapper who died of an apparent
overdose last year fans revealed on
social media that Ari played Miller's
music before stepping out on stage
naturally the Twitterverse had all the
fields one user tweeted Ariana had Mac
Miller's music playing while people got
into their seats for her concert tear
emoji another wrote in part my heart
can't handle it so many tears and this
concert goer tweeted and they're playing
Mac Miller at the ariana grande concert
not emotional no no no not at all I mean
that one seems like they're in denial
but this one gave me all the feels I
mean that was a really sweet way to
honor him I like that a lot
it wasn't all tears at the show normanni
served as an opening act for the thank
you next hit maker slaying in a
skin-tight black glitter jumpsuit after
the big night she captioned this post
stiff wear I don't know if it means the
pop star stoked up the big day even more
backstage posing next to commemorative
billboard plaques to celebrate her
record-breaking singles it's been a
really big year for Ari yeah
Ariana also used her platform for a good
car I love this so much I know she
partnered with head count org to set up
voting booths to register new voters the
stations were filled with the cutest
ariana song references are you ready for
this yeah you like my rights
gee thanks just voted just voted and
voting stickers with the Thank You
next-gen hashtag now the sweetener tour
comes on the heels of a world one year
for Ariana she recorded her album while
suffering panic attacks and after that
Manchester concert bombing in 2017 she
choked up about it in this interview
like helping each other through scary
times and like anxiety you know some
Turks out there man we just have to like
be there for each other isn't that just
a can cuz you never can know you know so
I wanted to do something to make people
feel good
Oriana is so resilient and this tour
proves just that and I gotta be honest
when you said sweetener I was like
that's gotta be wrong because she'd
sound like a whole another album since
then she's got a lot since then a lot in
a little amount of time now this little
girl yes now we will of course keep you
updated with all the latest on the
popstar so be sure to subscribe to ET
until next time I'm at Kourtney
underscore tezo know I'm a - Charlson
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]